Айлі Касаджі пощастило.
Куля її лише трохи зачепила.
Вона була в епіцентрі подій, коли рік тому в Стамбулі
сталася спроба путчу.
Айла та її чоловік із сотнями інших прихильників президента Ердогана
вийшли на вулицю проти путчистів.
Військові відкрили вогонь.
Ми знали, що вони стрілятимуть у нас.
Але мені не було страшно. Я лише думала про те,
що без батька та матері мої діти виростуть,
а от без батьківщини - ні.
Айла - затята прихильниця Ердогана.
Її навіть нагородили медаллю
"ветеран 15 липня".
Уряд звинуватив прихильників ісламського проповідника Гюлена
у спробі пучту. Але багато хто
має сумніви щодо офіційної версії.
Тут, у внутрішньому дворі парламенту в Анкарі,
під час путчу скинули бомбу.
Серед депутатів, які тієї ночі перебували тут,
був Айкут Ердогду. Він підозрює, що
уряду було заздалегідь відомо про спробу путчу.
Путчу спеціально дали можливість відбутися,
аби потім розпочати антипутч.
Ми марно закликали слідчу комісію допитати
начальника генштабу та керівника спецслужб.
Обидва знали про путч за 8-9 годин до того.
То як могло статися, що уряду
про це нічого не було відомо?
Утім, ставити такі запитання нині в Туреччині небезпечно.
Багато депутатів - колег Ердогду
сидять нині у в’язниці. Понад 140 тисяч
імовірних противників уряду Ердогана
впродовж року були звільнені
та понад 50 тисяч - заарештовані.
У країні відбулося разюче згортання демократичних прав і свобод.
Ті, хто стоїть за організацією
цього путчу, мусять бути притягнуті до відповідальності.
Але в рамках слідчої комісії
нам цього не вдалося зробити.
Наша система правосуддя нині в сумному стані.
Тому я не думаю, що буде справедливий
і незалежний суд.
Подружжя Касарджі жодних сумнівів
у своєму президентові не має.
Якби президент міг завадити цій спробі путчу,
він би це, безперечно, зробив.
Але з якоїсь причини він цього не зміг.
Можливо, були якісь комунікаційні проблеми.
Попри отримані поранення, подружжя Касарджі
готове будь-якої миті знову вийти
на захист Ердогана.